an inconsistent beginning to the year
but merrill has gone two and oh in his
last three starts
was pretty good last time out against
the padres went six strong innings gave
up only
one run on four hits in that game walked
a couple batters but he did strike out
five you see what he's done over his
last three starts
a few weeks back and this is bounced to
the middle of the diamond
and i think tap beat it hey that is a
leg hit
as josh rojas got to it and did
everything right
and tapia with the good wheels has an
infield single to begin the afternoon
fastball swing and a miss boat hangs on
to the final tip that's out of number
two
[Applause]
fastballs a strike two strikeouts in the
inning for
merrell kelly who strands two puts the
zero up there
[Applause]
and you get a bouncer that goes over the
head
trejo now throw it back the other way
we'll get it out
alan trejo gets pavement smith trying to
move up
great tag as well by mcmahon so trejo
who made an error that's why
smith is odd he said i'll get you back
and he did
what a play in short right field
that's a highlight reel sequence for
alan trejo
off the mound what a scope there by van
mater
got him josh van mader hot shot up the
middle
second number position properly
ball hits off the side of the mound took
a squirrelly hop out there right in
front of josh van meter he stays with it
and fires on to first to get the out
nice play
quick glove hand there and paving just
tall enough
tcb baby i got you alan trejo now in the
second baseman
got him daryl kelly
three strikeouts d-backs and rockies on
valley sports
no score nick heath in the center field
today
boy if it's not garbage and snakes
that's fair down the line marshall's on
the move
it bounces away from tapia here he comes
diamondbacks grabbed the early lead
nick heath the rbi double nick heath
slashing one down that left field line
and dalton barshall gets to showcase
that speed
yeah boy nick first extra bass hit in
the d backs uni for nick
had a full count to ryan mcmahon before
he lost him with the bass on balls and
then struck out matt adams to win the
first
now a 3-2 to hampson
curveball got him for strikeout for
merrell kelly
good 3-2 breaker there looks like it's
going to be a strike on the outer third
of the player
torre calls those advantage counts when
the hitter has a 2-0 or a three-in-one
count and your pitcher is almost forced
to throw something in the strike zone
and obviously you want to avoid
advantage counts if you can
this ball launched stay fair it's long
gone that is a
fair ball back to back nights
home runs for trevor story in a ballpark
he owns
and the rockies are in front 2-1 13th
all-time at chase field is
fourth this year overall
that ball was absolutely crushed switch
hitter eduardo escobar he also hit a
deep fly ball to hampton in center and
this ball
is toward tapia and he lays out and
makes a
gorgeous catch that was it
fair ground nobody likes it more than
chichi gonzalez
wonderful diving catch by tapia
the rockies flashing the leather this
afternoon they're up two to one going to
the fourth
punches that one down the line but on a
flame
what a play that's cross off lisa cross
our golden glove no cross
up there what a play by lisa cross down
the right field line
let's go to the video tape
that's not an easy place slicing off the
bat of a right-hander
whoa lisa we're gonna have to change her
nickname
she can't be cross-up anymore i know
this is bunning in the air and the
diving
catch was it made i think it was diaz
great job
i i love that effort for a couple
different reasons
one he's he's laying his body out there
but two you don't know what's going to
happen people say well just let it go
foul
and then you know touch it then because
it's the third strike it'll be out
anyway
but you're not even taking that no
you're not he's just
laying out sacrificing the body two down
now
for paving smith who is over two here
goes varso
pavon smith high fly ball right field
it's gone d-back's answer back gets 3-2
just the second home run given up this
year and
chichi gonzalez number three for pavon
gonzalez went with that little cut
slider ended up on the inner third of
the plate right there
he has really helped fill the void this
year paving smith with all these
injuries d-backs take the lead right
back
eduardo doesn't hit a lot of balls to
the left center field gap as a
left-handed hitter but he's got a ton of
room out there right now
[Applause]
wow bob bradley you called it that's
going to get to the wall
van mater's coming around third he will
score
and we're though escobar with the rbi
double
are you psychic but you have to play
everything
even up because he's foul line to foul
line infield and outfield
and this is to left field and it'll make
it a one-run game
third hit of the ball game for tapia out
there for hampton the tying run in the
eighth
ground ball toward the middle of the
diamond on through hampson comes through
tapia scores the rockies are even with
arizona
4-4 in the eighth two
two out ribbies in the inning
ow that hit him on the finger oh no
oh oh first thing
obviously that there's no fracture
yeah he's staying in the game and then
you know thinking ahead 24 hours
you know is that does it become so
[Applause]
it's in the corner here comes van meter
the freight trains on the run peralta
coming in vote headed for third hayes
got the tur
run triple and vote comes up with a big
one to make it six to four
way back deep left center
josh rojas off the wall
vote will score it rolls back to center
7-4 joshua hawkes
is at it again
[Applause]
deep to center hampson backing up this
one's off the wall
here comes rojas dalton varshall has an
rbi double
and the diamondbacks have an 8-4 lead
escobar third to second ball game
diamondbacks win it and his career win
number 300 as diamondbacks manager for
torrey lavillo